the federal government is warning about
fake military draft notices demanding
Americans report for duty and deploy to
Iran the messages threatened the
recipients with jail time if they don't
immediately reach out to recruiters they
began to show up on people's phones just
as tensions mounted in the Middle East
Catherine Herridge is in Washington
Catherine do we know where these texts
are coming from well Anthony a military
spokesperson confirms to CBS News the
Army is investigating the text that
appeared to start on Monday they don't
have a source or a motive but the scam
seems designed to capitalize on the
conflict with Iran imagine getting a
text that threatens jail time if you
fail to report to the recruitment center
to be drafted into the US military got
me really nervous because I'm still in
high school a 10 year old George Barnes
received this text that read you've been
marked eligible and must report to the
nearest branch for immediate departure
to Iran except military drafts ended
after the Vietnam War of a completely
volunteer army and were abolished by
Congress in 1973 making the US military
volunteer only the text have been
received in states across the US and
don't seem to be targeting a certain age
or gender and come after the deployment
of more than 3,000 additional troops to
the Middle East following last week's
u.s. strike in Baghdad that killed
Iran's most important general I was just
really in a little bit of disbelief that
you know people out there would take
advantage of the situation that's going
on in the world right now commander
David Henning is an army recruiter in
jacksonville florida where at least 50
cases have been confirmed by CBS News he
was listed as a contact on some of those
messages it would take an act of
Congress and with presidential approval
before in a really a global
international emergency to necessitate a
draft and and they should just disregard
the text message
the army said it's not contacting anyone
regarding the draft and the texts are
not official communications this is a
trap they're trying to get you to
respond and then at some point when
they've got you in a more compromised
position they'll request money wired
editor-in-chief Nicholas Thompson says
it's a scam designed to make people
panic during a tense time and not to
fall for it
there's no doubt in my mind that it's a
bunch of people who have run a bunch of
other scams and know how this works at
how the psychology works and they're
sitting there saying hey what's the
issue with the most emotional intensity
right now
oh it's the killing of sulemani let's
get in on that there's no evidence yet
that anyone's been compromised hacked or
had anything stolen the army told CBS
News to always go to an official website
for information and not to click on any
links and to delete the messages scale
all right got it Catherine thank you
very much it's got to be very jarring
though guys awful but Nick is right they
get you riled up and then they're gonna
ask for money please don't fall for it
you